Once upon a time, a pregnant woman wished
for strawberries, when she did not receive
them, her daughter born a few months later,
a strawberry shaped mark on her forehead.
Or so the story goes in much of ancient history.
Hey Guys, Julia here for DNews
Birthmarks can often be a source of embarrassment
for some.
A mistake of DNA can lead to an deposit of
melanin or a tangle of veins.
But surprisingly, not a lot is known about
them.
Scientists split birthmarks into two main
categories, vascular and pigmented.
Caused by increase in melanin in one spot,
pigmented birthmarks are mostly harmless.
Moles, Café au lait spot, and mongolian spots
are the big three kinds.
Pigmented Nevi, or more commonly known as
moles, are dark skin cells that grow in clusters.
Cafe au lait, are a little more spread out
and a lighter brown or tan.
Mongolian spots, are bluish purplish spots
and appear when melanocytes get trapped in
a deeper layer of skin.
And are typically found in people of East
Asian descent.
They go away as kids get older and are almost
always gone by puberty.
More is known about vascular birthmarks however,
The most common are stork bites, pink or tan
patches that appear on babies’ neck.
It’s estimated that as many as half of all
newborns get one.
Similar to spider veins, the stretching of
some capillaries causes the patches to appear,
and they too usually go away after 18 months
or so.
Another type of common birthmark are little
strawberry like marks called infantile hemangiomas.
These are basically benign tumors in the cells
that line blood vessels.
One study published in Journal of Clinical
Investigation found that these marks originate
in one type of cell which express a protein,
CD133.
From these cells blood vessels form, but then
they disappear leaving behind fat cells which
make the marks stick out.
Another study published in Pediatric Dermatology
found a connection between oxygen depletion
in the placenta and the development of these
type of birthmarks.
Yet some research from The Medical College
of Wisconsin and Children's Research Institute
suggests that low birth weight is the single
greatest factor in developing an infantile
hemangioma.
Most of them disappear after a few months,
but up to 10% of them can cause some problems,
like getting so big it impacts vision or breathing.
Some birthmarks indicate a serious underlying
issue.
Port-wine birthmarks are pretty common, about
one million people in the United State have
the reddish elevated spots.
Like stork bits and hemangiomas, they form
when capillaries don’t grow correctly, yet
these can grow and thicken over time.
They can sometimes be a hallmark of Sturge-Weber
syndrome, in which patients have abnormal
blood vessels in the skin, brain and eyes,
which cause the symptoms of the disorder.
One study published in the New England Journal
of Medicine found a single genetic mutation
on the gene GNAQ is associated with the disorder.
From this run down, it’s clear more research
is need, get on it science!
Alright guys, do you have a weird birthmark?
Let us know in the comments below.
While you’re at it don’t forget to hit
those like and subscribe buttons and keep
coming back here for new episodes every day
of the week.